having a little bit of a party in here
that's what I had to work with you know
for six months I want to pose a question
to you both of you that you posed in the
movie are you a typical example of your
sex I'd like to think of myself as above
every above-average
I got ever submitted or am I probably I
think I'm a typical game does that help
are you a typical example of your sex or
am i above average oh my god
the Houston family are more than proud
of their of their male offspring so are
you above average what would you say
this in producing I'll ensure it was
pretty rare for every perfect so I know
Chris said that when he met with you
about taking on this role you acted the
film out to him I think you said it took
about two hours but you acted the whole
thing out can I get a tiny little
synopsis the best way to direct an actor
is the subtlety of attitude so you could
talk and you can talk and you could talk
or I just none of that done hmmmm you
know anyway and they get it if accuracy
all the time I was in you want and then
you and then you know they acted out
looking incredible and then cut to me
and like sweatpants like in the film
she's never met a man before and Chris
Berg has to explain men to her if you
made a man that had never met a woman
before how just wing women this is
different than that isn't it right and
how would you describe a man who am i
describing you come in there like Chris
Pine you're sit there like I think
there's the desire to win there's a
competitive nature there's the there's
the hunter and they desperately need a
woman kind to nurture and to convince
them that the real power is love
we pulled FN dango fans across the
country this is the most anticipated
movie of the summer well how do you like
that we do give me this you yeah you
gave me a chills in the movies I I mean
that moves me beyond words I can't
I have loved water woman as we as many
of us have for so long but to see people
say like I needed this I want it like oh
my god that's the greatest thing
thank you guys can we end on this thank
you thank you Wonder Woman
yes I can
[Music]
[Music]